all right jj
yeah jj where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i i grew up in los
angeles california
tell me about your family you had both
your parents when you were a kid yes
well no my family was divorced uh
divorce by the time i was five years old
you were raised by your mom well i was
raised by my my father
and my grandmother
and where was mom well my mother stayed
in compton california
and uh they kind of like took me from
her when i was uh
uh of age or born like maybe two years
old
my grandmother took me from my mother uh
because she felt i was my father's kid
after a while so they took me and then
my father and mother divorced
how would you describe your childhood
well i i had
a very i didn't i really understand my
childhood i didn't get to play a lot as
a kid
my father kept me with him always riding
around in the car with him
and uh i just didn't have a lot of
friends at an early age
you know and um
from there my uh my uh
sister was my grandmother's favorite
and so what happened there is after a
while my mother
when i turned about eight my mother uh
wanted us back
so she went to court and she got us back
and my grandmother just developed some
real
uh messed up feelings towards me because
she felt it was my fault
for asking and constantly asking where
was my mother at
and um so she uh my mother got us back
and from there uh
my mother started having problems uh
with alcohol and drinking
so my father found another reason to get
us back
and and once he got us back uh my
grandmother just
had this type of hatred for me and
she would uh just at an early age make
me
sweep clean the house my sis gave my
sister everything and uh
didn't give me too much of anything as a
kid
and um from there my grandfather used to
take me in the back house we had a back
house
also with the front house and uh my
grandfather used to uh molest me as a
kid
and uh make me uh
just have oral sex with him as as a kid
which i knew nothing about at that time
how old were you i was about seven and
eight
when he used to do this and uh
i think once my auntie came to the door
and she saw it and
she didn't even say anything about it
she just kept doing what she was doing
so this kind of messed my head up coming
up as a kid i
kind of thought that maybe they were
this was a part of life i didn't know
any
any better than that and uh so as i grew
up and got older
i um just didn't know which way to go in
life
you know and i ended up at a very early
age here on skid row
and i was here for
wow maybe 23 the age of 23 to now
uh being very uh indecisive on what life
was
i always felt like i was alone
and nobody really cared my family didn't
i remember once when i went to stay with
my mother at um
probably about 18 or 19 and try to give
it another go
my stepfather at that time she was uh
remarried he didn't uh
too much like me so uh i
ended up after going to work i used to
have to sleep in the uh
the cupboard in the car shed in the
garage
in the parking stall we had some
apartments and there was a parking stall
over the
top of the garage and i used to have to
go sleep
inside the garage the parking stall
uh it's like i can hear my mother going
to work in the morning and start her car
up and she wouldn't even know that i'm
literally in the parking stall right
above the car
uh going to sleep and uh
just had a horrible life growing up
having to go through all this stuff
i felt like nobody really cared and i
didn't know which way to go in life
and uh once i hit skid row it was just
so much of the same type of uh
stuff down here a lot of people that was
damaged a lot of people that had mental
problems
are are drug problems and it kind of
it's kind of like i felt that i was uh
amongst people like myself you know and
i had the same type of uh
problems these people did and um it just
turned into
pretty much all of my life you know it
being my age now
i've been down here 38 years and um
i never just had too much to uh go on
never really know
um nobody to guide me nobody to tell me
that it was gonna be okay that it wasn't
my fault
the things that happened to me as a kid
uh i was constantly beaten by my uh
grandmother and my uncle coming up for
no reason at all
you know something wasn't dead right or
you know i said the wrong thing so i
costly was always getting beat and
whooped by the family and um
my life's just been a a horror story if
you ask me just growing up i don't
stuff i don't think a kid should have to
go through and i constantly uh
battle with this to the day i constantly
have to uh
try to figure out you know am i worth it
or why did i have to go through this
type of stuff as a kid
and um my life is uh
a little better now because i'm older
and i'm able to put a lot of stuff
behind me
and um i tried
uh or harder but things just keep coming
into play that
had to do with my childhood my childhood
and um a lot intellectually you can
understand that this is not your fault
yes but that doesn't really help you
no because your subconscious your
behavior no it doesn't help me because
it's all i knew growing up
you got to figure as a kid when it
starts at such an early age
and you're being beat you're being
molested you're going through all this
stuff and
nobody says anything about it you kind
of start believing it's your fault
did you ever feel like anyone loved you
no i didn't feel like i was loved as a
kid
i felt like i was told what to do all my
life and how to do it
and if it wasn't dead that way then i
was going to be in trouble
for some reason that's how it usually
ended up and uh
when i grew up and and learned that what
my grandfather was doing wasn't right
that even had more of a play on my my
mind because now i had
bottled all this stuff inside of me and
i was afraid to let anyone know
uh i didn't ever my mother passed
not even knowing this i never told her
at all that i was constantly molested as
a kid
uh she never even knew it
you know and she passed going to her
grave not even knowing
what my uh grandfather on my father's
side had constantly done
to me i just was felt so ashamed of it
or i
didn't know how to explain it to her so
uh i just kept that a secret all of my
life
this is probably only the second or
third time in my life
that i've even mentioned that to anybody
what had uh happened to me at a kid is
just something i kept as a secret
inside of me how is it how has that
affected your life as an adult
it's it's affected me a great deal
because uh i i'm
certain it has but i'm wondering like
well i i feel unworthy
i feel unworthy of uh anything uh
i feel that mentally people
can look at me and and know that i have
been through stuff
you know i'm hurt i'm ashamed
and um there was never nobody to talk to
about it
have you had romantic relationships
yes i have had romantic relationships
with women or
men with with with women mostly uh
other things with me and i would try
because i uh
didn't know if this was me right you're
confused by that yeah i was confused
uh so i didn't know what was going on in
my life so
uh i i just felt the right way was with
women
but i just didn't know uh what i was
going to do
you know in my life so i've always been
confused uh
uh sexually in that part uh because of
uh
my lifestyle and i grew up like that and
i grew up not being understood
um by women because they never knew my
uh background
and they never knew what was wrong with
me why i would go through certain things
um so my life has just been a
complete disaster
is the best i can put it you know it's
just been a disaster from day one
and to the part that sometimes i wonder
if i was cursed or something
maybe there's a curse over me and uh or
my whole family or something and i just
didn't know
uh and there's nothing i can do about it
and that's the bad part about it feeling
that you
going through all this in life and not
feeling there's nothing you can do about
it
you know there's no healing to it
because it's just the way life is
are you living on the street yes i'm on
the streets now
i've been on the streets uh every now
and then i'll try to make a break and do
something positive
but i i think because of what i go
through mentally i always
run back to this because i don't know
how to really deal with people
uh and what's expected of me so i uh
just come back to the streets right i
feel a part of it
yeah are drugs part of your life drugs
is part of my life also
i i think i started using drugs to um
self-medicate and to uh try to
block the memories of what i go through
and uh a lot of times they would help
not knowing that what they were doing
was actually putting me in more
to the whole lifestyle and and becoming
an addict
uh because of the drug scene and i think
that entrapped me even more
into skid row not being um aware
uh or practicing right and wrong or
what's good and bad
uh this whole thing down here has became
a lifestyle to me
you have all these emotions that must
come up from this
yeah i've never knew how to deal with
emotions i i messed up so many
relationships because of the emotions i
uh what do you deal with most is it
anger or depression or anger
depression i believe it's depression and
anxiety
is what i deal with most and i i've
never been treated for either one
so i don't know how to handle them and
uh sometimes i'd sleep for days
like now i just got up after a two-day
sleep
it's like i don't even want to open my
eyes and look at what i'm going through
in life
you know so i just try to sleep it away
until i just have to get up and go eat
and
take care of myself
what was the worst point in your life
the worst the worst part of my life was
uh
i i believe have to uh
i i had a daughter
and because of all the uh confusion in
my head i didn't know how to even be a
father
to her i didn't know how to say well i
went through this
so i'm going to make sure she had a
better life
so my life uh you know just
turned out where it was affecting a
young child's life just like mines was
affected
and uh where she had to go stay with
other people too i just didn't know what
she had went through in her life
uh if it was similar to mine so um
it was i can say that was the worst part
of my life
having a child and not trying to do
better by that child
and not knowing if her life is just as
messed up as mine
what's your view on on life is is it
is it just people are evil and
dog-eat-dog and just every man for
himself or do you feel
i mean do you feel betrayed by by your
family
i think it's a little bit of all of it i
i think if if it would have been
more interest taken into me as a child
then maybe i wouldn't have uh i would
have understood
something easy for you to have a very
negative view on yes on
existence right exactly with what you
went through
i would have been able to uh see things
more positive
and and separate some of the things and
saying okay that happened
and it was a bad thing that happened but
you know just told to move on that i'm a
good person
or something i've never had that
positive input really
um a lot of times so i
my view of life is that it it was just a
bad place it's people were all bad you
know
nobody really understood uh or cared
about the next person it was all about
what they can get out of life
and uh i was just a pawn in it
you know and people were only
people were selfish they didn't really
care about me or anybody else
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life the most important
lesson i learned
in life is not to give up uh
like i said even though i've been down
here all these years
even though i went through everything i
went through in life i think the most
impersonal lesson i learned is not to
give up on it
uh that it that it is my life and it's
it's mine to make the best of so uh each
day i get up i stand and i still
think that something's going to happen
for me something's good is going to
happen
and all this turnaround and i think i'll
just continue to think that and believe
that until the day i go
you still have hope i still have hope
that's excellent yeah so
it's great to hear i have to hope that
you should thank you
do you ever have urges to do what was
done to you
with with children that's a common story
um not to a child not to a child i think
because it was done to me as a child
i uh i think it's uh
the wrong thing to do to a child i think
when i was younger i didn't know the
difference
between a child and an adult and so i
didn't understand what was
being done to me was wrong but as i grew
older
i understood it was wrong because i was
a kid so
uh to a child no i i don't understand
that because i didn't understand what
was done to me and i wouldn't want
another child to
have to go through that good for you
yeah you've been through a lot that kind
of derails your whole the way your brain
works
after that doesn't it yes it does i mean
i i think i'm a fairly and still
a fairly intelligent person you know and
like i said i have tried to reach and
get out of here
i believe every situation i've been put
in in life
uh coming up and the people i've met was
a uh
something that i i needed to learn
to continue to cope with life uh the
good and the bad has all been just
things to help me uh become a better
person
and uh like i said i still want the best
i still i still want to believe that
someday this will all be behind me
and i can uh achieve something out of
life
and maybe help others that were went
through the same thing i don't know
maybe i can talk about it one day where
i can there's other people just like me
out there
who need some type of a guidance and i
can tell them what it took for me to
just live this long and continue to
believe that life is going to be uh
okay for me yeah you deserve everything
that life has to offer
yes exactly i wish i hope it comes your
way
yes exactly all right jj thank you so
much for sharing your story
and thank you i wish you best of luck
thank you thank you
you know i haven't told nobody that
whole story before really
never told anybody that whole story how
does it feel
[Music]
well it feels okay and then i do
i feel like because what is my family
going to say because i've never told
them
well i mean they really can't condemn
you for
talking about yeah they they're the ones
that should they need to know
i would say so yeah maybe they need to
know but i have never said and told
anyone that whole story before
and uh maybe maybe all this happened
because it's time that somebody uh
needs to know wow that's why he's going
through that yeah that's why he
you know i mean as an outsider who just
met you looking at you you're handsome
you're intelligent you speak beautifully
you
you present yourself really well yeah
and yet i'm sure you have this very
negative view of yourself because of
because of that childhood yeah i know
not just the molestation but everything
else the way you were treated
yeah and you don't deserve any of that
you deserve to live the best life you
can possibly dream of yeah
and yet you're here on skid row living
like a yeah i don't know i'm like it's
just like when you came walking up i'm
like well he's not yeah
he's not somebody i want to interview
yeah but your story is incredible
thank you you don't deserve a bit of it
thank you man no one does
i appreciate you